buddy you know coming back okay well
thanks everyone this was so much fun
while it lasted never been stronger
rebuilding is so fun the Jets have been
doing it for years
oh yeah we're not rebuilding yes you are
I can clearly see you restructuring
everything
yeah no nothing's changed we're still
really good Jimmy are you gonna help me
nah spilled around me finally I'll
rebuild is over hey I'm not hurt this
time
seeing me just hit the nail Hugh the
nail may not get hammered
but Browns fans certainly will
the Patriots do not rebelled we re
allowed coach sure we cool now
coach these plays are from before they
invented the forward pass why is every
guy in routine 40 years I'll tell you
what man you might have players with
your personal brands in your screen
passes sometimes I wish I could just go
back in time man oh thanks for paying
for this time machine instead of Khalil
Mack oh of course
Johnny I love chase in the past bringing
me back to when football was football
and men were men man mm same office same
haircut wait I know you meant coach it's
me Rich Gannon tell you what a reliable
quarterback I'd off to pay I went back
in time man my god Rudin clean tackle
can't wait to practice all offseason
with no restrictions
I'm in heaven oh hi coach have you met
our terrible backup yet hello I'm Thomas
whoops ha ha ha thank goodness for the
Tuck rule even clumsy rookie idiots can
drop the ball and it's still not a
fumble mark you gotta bring me back 20
18 mental blocks Shrek I'm sorry but his
brain is trapped in 2002 forever and
that's the radar way
my do you leave me here bro tell us
you're retired it's not safe for you to
be on your own I mean you're gonna use
I'll come visit maybe dirt bye bye week
that's not tow week nine brothers never
visit so it's pretty neat here you can
help the retired Cowboys call bingo
games okay so based on this formation
I'm guessing the next ball will be n 24
what he said hey whit oh it's Marty when
I move this is a retirement home crime
drop 100 percent here we see our
exercise programs my EC is record of
25,000 but I think I can beat that now
I'm sure Canada will call soon too you
know I still think they comply this
place sucks
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
Martellus you're 31 there's nothing out
there for you anymore I survived a 28 to
3 deficit I'm not going out like this
Cuddy anyhow cigarette
there we go miss communicating again ah
retired athletes have no love
I have assembled the greatest con men in
the NFL do just well enough to get the
money then your talent disappears but
fitzy you've stolen millions from the
Rams bangles bills Titans Texans Jets
what else is this I'm gonna steal the
starting QB job for the Bucs
here's the plan
I caused a distraction in the media ahem
I went to Harvard but I'm wearing silly
clothes next we need a QB controversy
that's where Sammy sleeves comes in what
maybe you should start the rookie Dalton
Marvin I need you to get people excited
but still lose a wild card game Allie
AFC North really up for grabs
at this point no one will know what it
takes to be an NFL quarterback and if I
play one good hand I'll get the job now
eventually I'll be exposed uh sir you're
gonna want to see this only I get to be
overpaid
get up Tannehill that's what you confuse
everybody there are three you know and
they'll have to start me any questions
why don't we just play great football
all the time because that's so hard
there is it just me or does this year's
course season carnival gonna soft sir
have to leave no sorry
hey look guys I finally hit the target
I'm sorry I know everyone's rooting for
me don't worry the Colts will help you
win come right booger McFarland sideline
machine sir you're up
no not yet man where's Eli he said he'd
connect with us here he'll QP I'm all
done scared good oh you're polite now
remember I'd love to I can't meet Eli
where are you I won't leave my corn
pocket a fast rush you're looking for a
pasture any quarterbacks I'm looking for
any non-controversial quarterbacks
anybody on the Steelers well yeah Shh
Don't Tell no siree Bob that maze is too
tricky for me waffle is Mose
after a loss you ever feel invisible no
mostly because people are always
extremely mean to me I was like yo I'll
never grab that ring but my god have you
seen my stacks whoa
crows only remember the Titans we lost
to the bills and nobody knows we exist
yeah we should be household names right
Corey Davis right Derek Henry we need a
makeover for the gridiron heights
homecoming dance I heard you're looking
for a culture change well I used to play
linebacker whoa so relatable first we're
gonna touch you guys up with some
underperforming Patriots next we'll give
you a whole new look Wow
two-tone gray sleeves lastly it's all in
the attitude here we go for it on fourth
down now so we're basically the same
team that fired our coach after winning
a playoff game and may slide roster
changes whoa we're the Titans I need him
to beat me one more time this year
hi look at those you knees whoa that's a
true big market team above ever seen one
Wow the Rams got hot over the summer
oh I like to report a crime in North
Jersey I think you look Manning in for
killing the time - you know my buddy
O'Doul said I'm a murderer well that's
just our relationship you know
I mean it's not like you and draft QB
over shake lon
yeah I think they probably should have
look I love the fence I would never harm
a fan but do I think they protect Eli
Eli won two Super Bowls against us so
now they're stuck with him forever
rumors are there's tension Eli can't you
Passport
shoot your best receiver now we must
only shut down no comment no comment but
yes I am loving this but get over you
won't believe what Gurdon did now
yeah we don't even need to be good to
win this division anymore look I barely
killed the Giants I'm not capable coach
up here to bail you out again okay sorry
I have to have my family yelled amorous
bye what the hell did I ruin the Giants
of course
Madi with only three wins I don't feel
safe we have no defense
don't worry Julio after the incident I
created a state-of-the-art panic room
Wow I could figure out about knots Cory
dude are you always stressing that your
30-point games aren't enough you need a
panic room today I think I miss my Super
Bowl window see season going poorly
panic with us well that's perfect I'll
take it that's not a lot I'm often
bother hundred one my brain is sort of
like my own panic room our rooms come
equipped with a place to tweet
frustrations a schedule to stress about
we play the Rams and the Pats and
podiums for you to insist you're not
panicking at I actually feel really good
about where we're at
thank you I just want to give up luckily
for you we have accepted defeat rooms
I'm not crying your crime each comes
with a Larry Fitzgerald to make it all
better okay if your team is garbage as
long as everyone loves you God he's so
classy
so by today because the season isn't
even halfway over
it's pretty awesome no one can mess with
us starting quarterbacks anymore sure
sure right yeah out of the way Vaughn
it's a quarter best game now god I hate
those pretty boys Brooke wait up I just
want to say four years ago in here I'm
allowed during the purge it's dangerous
out there they're celebrating with hip
thrusts oh my god he's mimicking a
weapon and he's wearing fun cleats to
play and not just as a pregame warmup
this is anarchy we need to get some at
Bryan's panic room the real purge it's
mental okay
no purges perjure the perchick go
through up here okay great okay thanks
for that you must love the parish
contest
what's the purge Baker I got purge
here's a tree an extra-long episode of
gridiron night told you this
neighborhood rules check down to be safe
check down to old I don't think I can
keep up with youse all well yeah well I
guess there's still the wild card the
purge is my cheat day sorry to sack you
no that's okay
great sack great job being set JJ look
I'm having a good season hey Jerry the
money is all mine now
good job now bring me more heads boys
doing this to us don't you see all the
good to purchase it lets the defense get
out their aggressions so during the
season we have record scoring good
listen new new bag
I must cleanse myself of a quarterback
every year
oh you are my best friend I'm so far the
NFC is mine what do we do
listen sometimes you're tied to the
chair sometimes a chain you're not as
good at Papa pieces as you think you are
all the fun is a purge
I wish there with you step up centers
hosted at flippin soccer practice sorry
man we're in mourning I looked out my
fantasy teams again nobody fluffing
respects us with a GT front more dancey
wildcard brah where are we
welcome to the Florida section of grill
iron Heights
if I never noticed this place probably
because it's only for underperforming
teams at quarterback controversies and
bath salts let me give you a tour I'll
take it from here
since I'm the most Florida person you'll
ever meet and I'm back over here we have
our own Hospital why aren't we getting
better
guess you need another year to evaluate
me and that's what the Jags deep breaths
okay why am I the only one who showed up
we've done 72 and I've sort of coasted
since then so where do you guys want to
eat here is let's go home you could be
the Kissimmee Chargers and play inside
the medieval times we need stars here
we've been starting a manatee at left
tackle for years Oh kiss my tuchus
I'm staying here but we just signed a
thousand year lease making another
culture change everyone yeah okay let's
leave
coach our flight to Mexico City doesn't
leave for another 10 hours hey you got
to be prepared for everything
[Music]
let's practice is Spanish I made you all
learn you know I hope it's cool that I
have like 20 carrier I'm detecting a lot
of weapons we have to potentially
explosive offenses better hurry uh you
gonna have a game good finish somewhere
I have the perfect play Oh God they're
both so innovative hey man we're the
same we're both frontrunners ha
I am very clearly affordable oh we made
it come on Travis can the play defense
always an afterthought
welcome to dinner for all the teams who
have to play on Thanksgiving
I brought my famous green bean casserole
it's pretty good but it's not gonna win
any awards I wish we can go out to the
bar tonight like the other dojos times
doing karaoke we've got some exciting
news in the middle of this grid iron
Heights episode Osborn V our bundles are
starting at 199 during Black Friday we
taste some more pepper hey man let me
take that I think you're finished pass
this around to Cleo just pass the earth
Mitchell a toast we may not see all of
you next year what but we love coming
together to friendly competition careful
Matt don't joke every page on get him
straight be fancy professional like me
hey Stafford you want seconds oh sure
I'm cold McCoy and I'm still the most
popular quarterback in Texas the NFC
East can be mine
interception I blame the fans Taysom
start the car already done sir hey what
exactly is taste Mills job No
Happy Thanksgiving
heythe you I just call and make sure
everything's a-okay yeah Andrew you call
five minutes ago I'm fine wait someone's
coming for the AFC South but I was only
heard for three years okay to you I go
deep the next part is very important
they're gonna take the deficient O'Kelly
don't know who you are
you don't know what you want but I'm
Andrew hello
I've a very particular set of skills
skills have acquired over almost half a
career skills like accuracy good
decision-making and recommending the
perfect flow sorry for evading in good
try though
so close skills that make me a nightmare
for people like you and I'm sorry about
that and you need to be focused so we
all play our best
he's got outdoors our data if you let
the AFC South go now that'll be the end
of it oh boy
what kind of a person would hang out in
a gross place like this oh hello mr. say
Andrew man I like you man but if you
don't I will look for you I will find
you you silly goose now absolutely
destroy him oh I can't tell if he's
threatening us or not hey guys you
forget how mobile he is get up I have
cover now
gather round for the week fourteen
playoff picture how do you all like your
sweaters get out of my way my home's
right if y'all can just behave I'll buy
LG french fries the foot okay I can do
this
I think you all will fit from my there's
white weight day clearly well uh Erin it
doesn't look like you're in I could just
get a little help okay well if we'd be
the Falcons and the Bears and the Jets
and of course needing the Seahawks and
the Vikings will lose out and the Bears
just stop playing football
wait where's the enemies sorry everybody
I think the Cowboys are in you stole my
sweater wha what what you doing little
guy I'm trying to make a playoff push oh
come on whit take control okay so I say
anything I can tell you carts out I
don't like that wait where did he go
nuts out great job everybody else
Seabreeze Wow
welcome to the Saints the first rule of
drew brees is you don't talk about drew
brees the second rule drew brees is that
when you do talk about him you mentioned
that he's a great football player but an
even better man oh like many of you I
was stuck I'd go through seven and nine
seasons and wonder how did these
consistent passing records define me as
a person I'd pray for a different life I
want you to line up as a receiver from
what I want you to line up as a receiver
what if we did wacky stuff on offense
all the time thus began Project Mayhem
did you go for it on fourth down which
time someone beat the Rams and a
question everyone is asking Who Dat our
offense is getting too dangerous we have
to stop this sorry sir we must do
everything to completions
his name was Desmond Bryan his name was
Desmond Bryan Oh coming back coach take
some pills taking over he's running he
passed the east blockage that's
impossible nobody like that exists you
were looking for a way to stop being
boring in grade so you made me up so you
could be interesting in great
everything's gonna be fine
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to the gridiron
heights Christmas party keep my layoffs
are coming oh no I'm freaking out no no
I'm not being replaced I'm still hurt
see Santa Cruden I'm gaming all my
players away okay and then I'm re for
you whoa hey you want to wear a car
hey how about you Dan Steinem man you
gonna be 125 million dollars Oh can't I
Jerry please
okay oh no this is a work event behavior
so that's a fine yeah well we'll seek
I'll find you - just give me get my
stuff you're having a party without me
I'm having the time of my life
Oh dad was this okay the NFC's a mess
yeah it is oh he's babysitting no I'm
going for wheel you guys don't go to bed
sterile gown I'm table I can run oh why
are these kids so mobile
another year without the postseason your
God or Dalai Lama or whatever I don't
know I'm still searching please show me
the way
Jordy Nelson now I hope you weren't
trying to tank tanking is a sin no but
sometimes I wish I was never even
drafted at all hmm that's an idea what
do you think Vince Lombardi okay I agree
you've never been drafted hey my legs
stopped hurting what I'm 49 years old
and I'm still the quarterback of my
pants
[Music]
without you Brett Farve wouldn't leave
the Packers haven't won a game in ten
years
State Farm shut down nobody was here to
discount double check the Bears won that
2010 NFC championship I'm Jay Cutler and
I never give up play clay don't you know
me Jordan get me back I want to be on
the Packers again hey hey hey watch it
the owners going to make changes we're
gonna hire someone with imaginative play
calling every time the whistle blows the
Packers still have more rings than the
Bears
[Music]
[Music]
listen up gentlemen you morons may have
only let me win 11 game we suck we're
not getting Minnesota miracles by the
Eagles this year maybe Kyra's last
chance before we replace them with
another cheap route I'm sorry sell down
I know everyone is depressed because
we're a two seed but we have to stick
together Gilmore what happens when were
five seconds late to a meeting we get
yelled at till we cry and crock remember
when you were unhappy with the team
Patriots tried to drink crunk after that
Brooke runs body and Josh Gordon remit
oh right
we have no Seavers mas get tackled on
the last play of the game reminds me of
the 1918 Dayton triangle Toledo Maroons
game where they had a secret
panty raid after a bye week boys and yes
there's stuff to worry about like aging
& Seek and the fact that bounty get
clearly angered god double doing
everyone Oh
welcome to elimination Creek Country
Club I believe you know your way around
that just give me a drink this son you
are very depressed the club is nice I'm
getting almost as much rest as I did in
the wild card game yeah
now all the charities know I have three
times the offseason I won't break it
football hey maybe I'm sorry sir
starters only at the club I'm a lead I
hope you wanna watch against five
starting quarterbacks next year not
again
never choke believe in yourself all
right well great season everyone see you
next year much love by the way man
I'm totally cool with outbursts so now
my fourth OC has left I have to wonder
am I the problem Kenan ba tough
elimination man that's okay this time
last year I was legally dead lol putting
it on oh no my power zone
I'm transforming that w Lucy's an egg so
the trick is you just have your family
yelled the owners how day must be the
players on the playoff course across the
street why are you having fun this is a
game
everyone here grid Ironhide gearing up
for the only game that truly matters the
pro again you boys didn't practice for
two whole days
to lose this game again clear eyes full
hearts robo coach I got the boats
I can play son I am so proud of you
you're a pro ball turn use the god
football and a 2019 AFC Pro Bowl team
guys my brothers hey um did you by the
way play for the Steelers
nice to meet you to meet you hmm the
Camping World Stadium in Orlando Florida
doesn't get much better than this they
played a Citrus Bowl here ok boys we're
just gonna play good old high speed
football with minimal tackling oh I'm so
bummed I can't play in this big game win
this for me son throw balls and memories
that's all you got
best place right you're embarrassing me
coach three children at home watching
the Pro Bowl
smile for even an elimination you have
become children of Brady we have a
twenty five point lead I feel like
people are never gonna let me get over
this one more and I'll have just as many
as the Steelers Thomas it's coming you
all in the AFC need to stop him if he
wins again it will be boring on a scale
this league has never seen prepare the
offense engage all defenses and get this
man a coach who can maximize a
serviceable Talent hey I'm a computer
man if something's wrong st. Louis is
deserted all that's left is baseball in
to Six Flags I need you to pay me it's
the only way to stop raining
is he okay
twenties in the AFC I will restore order
to the universe I want to take hell to
go it's working I see so many articles
about how this could be the end of the
Patriots dynasty ha ha budget Brady stop
like four feet of j-j-joey long down
give him back the balls bad geez get it
overtime overtime rules Tom gets a punch
first if he misses Patrick it's the
punch work the end of the game now Rams
are our last chance mean the Rams had a
bit of a falling out
yeah well I should win no I should win
okay Todd now might be a good time to
unleash the girl eh oh yeah something
weirds going on with me right now
Watts Ave white no-name position players
totally expendable attack oh thanks the
works a little better I don't even know
who you are
Garrett the system quarterback just like
you not true
you shouldn't have gone for my head no
rubbing the bathroom oh good a new sit
back hell yeah I get to disappear again
mister bruise hello
I blame the refs and I refuse to accept
this reality okay so that's one of the
14 million ways this could go down let's
practice it again
danos didn't go far enough hello you
have you feeling being jealous subscribe
to this channel to watch more episodes
oh I'm so light for this Hey
[Music]